Now there's one more thing I
want to add to our diagram and
that something to represent
the idea of multiplicity.
In object diagrams,
multiplicity is just a fancy word for
the number of objects
represented in a relationship.
This is another one of those things
that we're borrowing from UML.
Now multiplicity goes hand in hand
with the contains relationships.
If we look back at the world object,
let's ask yourself some
how many questions.
For example,
how many actors are in the world or
how many backgrounds are in the world?
We might say, for every world, we have
looks like it could be many actors.
Or for every world,
we might have one background.
And conventionally, we used terms
like one to many or many to many or
even many to one to
represent this multiplicity.
So right now,
if we think about the actors,
we can see that there's two actors on
the screen but there could be more,
or there could be worlds where
there's no actors at all.
To be honest we don't really know.
So we can do two things here.
Since we already have the app built we
could play around with it some more and
find out what are all
the different cases for
the number of actors in the world, or
for what would be the case if we're
designing this from scratch and
we didn't have the app already.
We could just make a decision and
go with it.
For instance, we could say, for
any given world there may be one to
many actors, we don't know how many,
there could be a lot, there could be
a little, it doesn't really matter.
We could limit it, we could say for
any one world there's only
ever going to be two actors.
But I have a little bit of an advantage,
because I already know that there
could be one to many actors in a world
and if we go back to our diagram,
we can add the multiplicity to this
contains relationship for actors.
And if we read the multiplicity
from left to right it
follows the same order as our arrow.
So for every one world we have,
we can have many actors.
Now let's look at another example.
This one will be for the contains
relationship for the background.
>From what we saw there is only
one background for the world.
So that means this relationship
is one to one, for
every one world object
there's one background.
The use of the one to many and
the one to one,
this is another thing that
were taken from you Mel.
So again this is kind of a blend of
both a formal and informal process.
There's something else that
I want to point out and
that is that the relationships
themselves and even the multiplicity can
go in different directions and
these arrows could be bidirectional.
For example, right now the world
contains one too many actors, but
you may want an arrow going from
actor to world that says, for
every one actor it could live
in many different worlds.
If it were the case that in the game,
an actor might show up in
multiple different worlds.
It's really up to you, you could build
these diagrams however you want but
these are just some really
popular conventions.
And if you stick close to these
conventions that it makes it easier for
you to share your diagrams with others.
It also makes it easier to take this
diagram and actually start writing code.
And that's why there are the formal
process is like EML in place because it
makes it easier to go from something
like EML to code or historically house.
There's one other key takeaway
that I want you to leave with and
that is that you should use a process
for creating object diagrams that's
the least restrictive to
you getting your work done.
I mean you could spend an entire day or
weeks designing an object diagram,
but if it doesn't get you any
closer to a functioning app,
then you might just
be wasting your time.
But there's also a great benefit of
having some kind of structure in mind
before you build it.
As a developer,
you'll discover what works best for you.
Some people like to spend five minutes
on an object diagram others could spend
an entire week.
And another thing is if
you're working with a team,
a good object diagram
could be a great way for
the whole team to work together to
understand a really complex system.
All right, I'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up here, but
if you're interested here's our final
diagram for the alien adventure.
So take some time to look at it and
maybe you have a better idea
how to organize things.
Anyways, I hope this was helpful and
I encourage you to reach out to us or
to your peers if you
still have questions.